okay he's dead anyone know what we do
next anybody Rose I have no idea anyone
else we bury him wrong ant check for an
organ donor card if he has one we only
have minutes to harvest
he has no wallet I checked he is an
organ donor yes yeah give me some ice in
a styrofoam bucket here we go we search
for the organs where's the hard brush is
hard I'm not feeling well let me just
tell me why you had to cut the face off
the dummy I didn't think it was very
realistic in the movie and it turns out
it's pretty realistic I've been staring
at this board for days so close to
putting it together there's gotta be
something we missed
let's go over this again the video shows
that the pie came from a high angle so
we're hit your face like this mm-hmm
don't close your eyes no no it actually
was from up higher is that about right
yeah
good clean yourself up let's do this
again all right let's go to the video
again sweet kid Lesley exits the
building and then you get hit what else
do we know we know that Leslie was about
15 feet in front of you
so clearly the assailant has terrible
aim or
Leslie wasn't the target well who then
okay that's permanent marker go find Ben
get a list of everyone he's ever fired
go go you son of a [ __ ] hey Jake can I
show you something over here sure thing
Webb trying to send Genevieve his sexy
pic just move my bubble butt pop nope
I'm out
excuse me pal squad meet detective
Adrian pimento
he's been deep undercover for the last
12 years but he's just resurfaced and
he's rejoining the nine-nine that yes
awesome you've reached the voicemail of
Dwight Kurt Schrute please
[Music]
I have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but I think it was worth it mom I was
laying on the ground defenseless and you
just kept throwing him until he exhausts
himself and then how about icing it lol
Dwight oh God
hey stupid terrible people
I need that birth certificate Leslie
wait here bert macklin is on the case
Andy no don't worry I can do this I also
got this dude's briefcases just laying
there kind of a panic move I believed in
you but you should put that back okay
questions what you do undercover I work
for Jimmy the butcher Figgis that is an
a-list mobster
tell me literally everything everyone
shut up pretty much just a bagman for
him I mean I did some other stuff we
usually try to tell funnier little
stories well there's nothing funny about
what I did for the butcher I've had to
learn not to blink because every time I
close my eyes I see a fresh horror ooh
dark gotta keep your eyes moist no
actually I have a very funny story about
keeping my eyes moist
no still not getting a vibe man
really mm-hmm I'll get there that's my
bad everybody say you excited yeah
very excited yes I'm very excited
extremely excited just very that's cool
I have spent a year here and I have to
commit or get out so Dwight's the top
salesman in the company and he's taking
me on my first sales call today and I'm
excited I am very excited
Ryan hasn't made a sale yet but more
importantly he hasn't made an ally yet
is he gonna be a slacker loser wiseass
like Jim was or is he gonna join the
dwight army of champions so what if
they're not talking about then does it
make sense to kind of lead the
conversation you know just till it gets
to a point where where they are asking
questions
so where's the sales office when you are
ready to see the sales office the sales
office will present itself to you your
journey begins now Annie and I are going
to take a walk and it's gonna be just
you poq itis and these pliers look I'm
not gonna torture this kid nobody said
torture why don't you let me take a run
at him boss in order to think like one
of these guys you have to think like
them yeah he's never seen you before
so imply that you're someone very
important and that you can make his life
hell greg pikitis would you like some
boiling hot coffee face my name is Bert
Macklin I'm with the FBI
huh looks like Andy's wearing him down
I'm gonna go finish him off just shut up
for a second he's a jerk he's being such
a jerk not crying okay lerczak two jerks
hi I'm Leslie Knope
this is officer Sanderson Bert Macklin
FBI how do you think you're doing you
can't just hold a 16 year old kid
against his will oh we were trying to
question him about this vandalism do you
have any evidence yes no two words no we
page pit peach-pit his DNA is all over
it I assume you don't know that we can
get it tested and if it matches your DNA
then you're going away for a long time
is this a joke no I'm calling your shift
commander Monday morning I am calling
your boss I don't know who to call about
you the President of the United States
of America
hey partner no I've been waiting for you
sorry if I surprised you it's just when
I was undercover the middle of the night
was the only time I could do actual
police work how'd you get in the
apartment oh it was easy
I just seduced the old lady upstairs
came down the fire escape jimmied the
window open bing-bang-boom I'm inside
your living quarters totally of course
next time you could just give me a call
you know two ways to pop in on a friend
I didn't kill the old lady upstairs if
that's what you're worried about playing
him now oh wait a minute you think I'm
being weird oh I shouldn't come here to
your apartment I'm so sorry Jake stupid
Paul stupid you yeah hey pimento who's
Paul whoa Paul Sneed was my undercover
name okay
damn it Jake I don't know who I am
anymore it shows any name we go
undercover and you picked Paul Sneed
seems kind of crazy this was a mistake
I'm not ready I knew I wasn't ready to
go back to being police jelly jump I've
ever had except for a bag of groceries
at the supermarket at the corner of
Atlantic and Clinton I guess I could go
back to that again paper or plastic
yeah still got it hey guys guess who's
back no need to thank me I'm not a hero
I am a mere defender of the office you
know who's a real hero hero from heroes
that's a hero
you